you have to learn in life when are the
moments that you must put the mask of
assertiveness if you're shy you don't
have to necessarily become an unshy
person you have to find out the ability
and the moments that you can put the
mask of assertiveness off
I don't have to be I'm shy and assertive
all the time but I have to figure out
the moments that I assertiveness will
serve me and I can put that mask on and
take on that persona for that moment 90
plus percent of the things that we're
worried and anxious about never ever
occur never trust the fact that there is
a lesson in that loss or that negativity
or whatever that is that when we first
have to trust that the lesson is there
and then if I could find that lesson and
hold it and grab it and and utilize it
for now then I don't have to stay back
there I think we stay back there because
we don't trust the lesson that we're
supposed to get from it oh we're doing
some live coaching here okay here we go
all right all right I'm ready
and there he is my man what's up baby
all good man we got Dr Corey Yeager in
the house he is the psychotherapist for
the Detroit Pistons of the NBA and he's
got a new book out called how am I doing
40 conversations to have with yourself
welcome aboard man thanks man thanks man
appreciate it there it is so uh I mean
I'm so excited about this in researching
your story and everything you're all
about uh one of one of my favorite
things that you said was that in the
work that you do that your job isn't to
change anything in somebody else but
it's to make them deeply aware and then
it's up to them to make the shift 100
what are the things that people are
struggling to have awareness of in
themselves
well I think there there's a
multiplicity of things and I think a lot
of the the things that we're struggling
with are very unique right
um so for instance one thing that you
could struggle be struggling with that I
see or hear people talk a lot about is
coping mechanisms that were developed
um on the heels of trauma when you were
younger right so you had a traumatic
event something happened when you were
nine years old
um and then what that nine-year-old
version of yourself would do is develop
some type of mechanism to deal with it
uh protective mechanism so for instance
if there was a trauma and you no longer
want to be touched by people you don't
want people to get close to you so you
become very shy all right I'm going to
be really shy and I don't want people I
won't talk to people so your
nine-year-old version of yourself sets
that up and you use that and it helped
you when you were not and it it
protected you but now you're 49
and you're still shy and you have to ask
yourself is that help me is that really
what I need anymore it helped to not it
helped protect the nine-year-old version
of myself
but I'm I don't think I need that
anymore but you can't really tune into
that unless you become aware of self be
curious with yourself ask yourself
questions why do I do that what is where
does that what is the root of that
where'd that come from
um and that's really what the book is
about is getting tuned into yourself can
people become unshy yeah because you can
become shy so you didn't have to be shy
all the time you you built that up as a
mechanism wasn't shy from the beginning
now I built that in so I could all of a
sudden not do that but then I could say
you know what I don't I don't want to do
that as much one thing I would say that
people could do in terms of like if
you're trying to be shy or not shy
you have to learn in life when are the
moments that you must put the mask of
assertiveness if you're shy you don't
have to necessarily become an unshy
person you have to find out the ability
and the moments that you can put the
mask of assertiveness on
I don't have to be I'm shy and assertive
all the time but I have to figure out
the moments that I assertiveness will
serve me and I can put that mask on and
take on that persona for that moment and
then you take it off and go back to that
shyness if that's what I choose but it
has to be again what I choose not just
what I end up being that makes sense oh
I love it so when people discover these
things you know the idea of someone
who's shy becoming unshy me you know
I'll uh I've identified as being
introverted and shy so so you're for
your example off the bat like it hits
home Dr Yeager and I was like okay he's
talking to me already how'd you know
that's good that's good uh and and so
you know man maybe that's in some deep
childhood trauma that I haven't kind of
figured out yet
um but that the process to then
change often can feel overwhelming and
giant and just an impossible tasks
especially if you are I mean I'm 42 your
example is 49 but you like to say how do
you eat an elephant well it's one bite
at a time so what what are the first
bites that people need to take once they
realize that you know oh my gosh I don't
want to be this person anymore well if
if I
if one person I think
I think and not wanting this little
thing that I do to take over so figuring
out what that that answer is first and
foremost what it is that you're trying
to do all right I just want to change
some aspects I love who I am but I want
to change this aspect of it
um I think that's you gotta you have to
be aware of that first and foremost but
then you have to go about
moving in a way that says all right I
want to change my shyness I don't want
this shyness all right so you don't want
this sadness any ideas where it came
from yeah not really I just kind of
always been chat all right so you've
always been shot there's not necessarily
a route that you you're grabbing a hold
of that produced it so then how do I
take a bite of that today tomorrow I'm
gonna say all right in that meeting next
Tuesday I have to present and I usually
am struggling with shyness and I just
kind of get through the parts of the
meeting and I sit down and I don't say
anything I'm not going to do that so I'm
going to take a bite out of this I'm
going to try some something a little
different when I go into this meeting
I'm going to talk to two or three people
that I normally wouldn't talk to
and people are going to be thrown off
like
he doesn't really use it what is he
doing he doesn't normally talk to people
so now you've got people off Rhythm and
I believe sometimes good to have people
off Rhythm I don't want people on rhythm
with me I don't know I want you saying
well what does he do uh yeah you don't
know what's coming next to you and you
shouldn't so finding ways in which to
address those issues little by little
you said how do you eat an elephant one
bite at a time so you don't try to do it
all and fix it all in the first moment
in the first minute or the first day you
try to take small pieces of work on it
see how that feels adjust it try it
again take another bite of it so I think
it's that approach
um that will El Aid Us in that process
how important is it to actually get to
the root so if I'm shy and I don't know
what my childhood trauma was it led me
to being shy does does it even matter if
I want to change it and I'm going to
take these bites and become more
assertive like does even does is it
worth doing the work does it matter
going back to figure out the route so I
think that that's why I was saying
earlier that you want to differentiate
so
it doesn't necessarily matter in every
situation to get to the root but in that
overarching aspect of who I am as a
person who I am how I feel about the
world my value systems those things have
deep roots to them and I believe that we
don't do a great job of digging into the
root system of Who We Are right you just
have value systems your parents told you
this is how we vote your parents told
you this is what we think and do and all
those things and you just took it you
talk about this though we just take all
this information people tell us how we
should do move and what we should be and
we just take it we don't really know how
to push back on it and then we look
around and say how'd I get to be where
I'm at and who I am and I don't even
know if I like this person I don't even
know if I like this version of myself
so now that's when it's going to call
for that digging into the root system
right now I'm looking around I don't
necessarily know if I'm down with it now
I did so that's that's my father so if
you ask me why am I shy like I don't
know like off the top of my head I don't
know okay do I
do you have a process are there
questions I'm supposed to ask myself do
I do I go lock myself in a cabin for a
week and meditate on it like how do you
how do you pull these things out of
people to help everybody
coaching here okay here we go all right
all right I'm ready
how would you define shy so you said
you're shy how would you define that
uh I I
uh historically don't go up and talk to
people so if I'm on the airplane I'm not
talking to the person next to me
um I'll I won't go and introduce myself
uh you know at events
um I hate Network answer historically
have hated networking events for like I
don't know anybody and
um
I get invited to go to dinners all the
time and it has historically given me
anxiety it's like okay like who's going
to be there and is there an easy way
home for me if I need to if I don't want
to be there anymore
um playing at my exit you know like if
it's a crew if it's a cruise you know I
said no to a San Diego cruise that was
like a three-hour cruise with some you
know big people in my industry just
because like I don't know if I don't
like it I I don't want to be stuck on
this boat for three hours listen but
hold on
wondering that's why I ask you to Define
it yeah because I I'm not shy at all and
I do those exact same things okay like
hey I'm not trying to hang out with
those people I don't want to do that and
I said it's zero to do with [ __ ] I just
don't I choose not to and I don't want
to be around I gotta I have to be on
it's that thing of being on like oh my
God I gotta be on I don't want to do
that this really has zero to do with shy
for me now I'm not saying it doesn't
have that anything to do with it for you
but again so you now all of a sudden you
started kind of explaining what your
version of shy means when you are
dealing with those moments of oh I gotta
do this I don't want to go up and talk
to people I'm on a plane I don't want to
talk to this person beside me I'm sure
you have mechanisms you put your
headphones in then right so they don't
talk to you right uh very probably yeah
I mean I just won't engage
um I think when I catch it then I can I
can make a more strategic decision as to
do I want to do this or not my concern
is I'm probably not even watching it
most of the time because that's the
default operating system yes and I think
that's and that's to some degree the key
so you're not catching it you're not
necessarily aware of it because
it's always done
you don't necessarily most people don't
even remember moments before you were
shy like I don't ever remember not being
shy like I don't ever remember not being
assertive I've always been asserted I
have no idea there's not been a moment
in my life that I can think back like
well you were pretty low-key then no I'm
pretty assertive putting it all on the
table no no
um no variance in that it is my default
um and I like that default but sometimes
people like you're saying I don't you
don't so you don't necessarily know if
that's what you want I'm just doing it
because it's what I'm used to if we be
if we're curious with ourselves and said
all right I don't know that this is what
I want anymore I want to change this
there are ways in which to continuously
engage saying when I get on the plane
and as soon as I get on the plane I'm
gonna say hey how you doing to the
person beside me that is absolutely not
who Evan is ah you're making my when
you're making my heart beat now here Dr
Yeager
even as I say it you can feel that Evan
you could feel that yeah yeah I'm gonna
tell him Dr Yeager said to say hi to you
this is my question if you said hi to
them yeah what would happen
probably nothing you know like if I
logically thought about it yeah then
nothing nothing would happen so there's
research that says 90 plus percent of
the things that were worried and anxious
about never ever occur never so we worry
and use all kinds of energy in the space
and they never happen so I'm I get
anxious about oh my God if I talk to
this person in I don't know and then I
do it and I say well it wasn't actually
it didn't end up being a big deal yeah I
did it and all right it was no big deal
yeah um so I think that's an important
thing for us to know especially that
anxious because anxiousness Evan is
something that a lot of people are
dealing with these days coming off of
covid it's happened but anxiousness
seeks to isolate it breeds itself if you
get it isolates it wants you to isolate
so it can breed itself
same thing with depression it wants us
to isolate ourselves so it can breed
itself so recognizing that I think is a
really important thing because sometimes
we shouldn't be isolated because we
don't want that anxiety to breed itself
and get bigger and then now expands us
into overthinking about things that
probably won't ever come to fruition
right so I talk too much no no it's
great no I'm listening I'd rather you
talk than me I don't learn from me
talking
that's not true that's true that's what
it's about you learn from talking about
so that's actually true there you go
nice comment I appreciate it uh yeah
honestly like if this happened 10 years
ago I would I would have said no you
know because that would have been too
worried or nervous or like I don't know
what questions to ask or what you're
gonna say and and I had to I mean we've
had Tony Robbins on and Matthew McCain
McConaughey on Deepak Chopra on like
some big name people on the show and Dr
Corey Yeager let's go
and I I that's a mental exercise for me
to say okay yes I'm going to be into yes
business because it's not just good for
my business and what I'm doing but
hopefully you know getting your message
out here it serves even more people and
that's really what I want to do so
that's been a mental exercise that I've
gotten better at but 10 years ago would
have been an impossible battle at that
point yeah I like that I mean and that's
growth right I mean that's the evolution
yeah it's personal Evolution and if
we're not evolving and getting better
and moving in certain directions then
we're stagnant I say it all the time
that in life we must be Rivers not ponds
ponds are stagnant right rivers are ever
moving and ever evolving and ever
regenerating themselves got to keep
moving
um and that doesn't mean it's easy but I
want to keep moving I want that movement
in my life all the time another key
message or theme that I love about your
work is you talk about your dad passing
away he was when you were 15 and that
you believe that he gave you everything
that you needed to grow like there was
you know he gave you what he needed you
you weren't like missing out like oh I
wish I had him for another 30 years and
like he had so many more lessons to
teach me you just believe that hey I'm
trusting it's going to unfold for me
as I as as it's supposed to be as
opposed to living kind of in the past
how do you develop that mindset uh what
are the values that you've seen coming
from it just it's a weird way of
thinking and so like I love I want to
just pick on that thread a little bit
Yeah I think that that the development
of that mindset was almost
to free me from holding on to dang my
pop say here man this moment he would
have been cool if he was here in this
moment and as my kids were born man my
dad being around and I just said I don't
think about any of those things I do
um but I don't Linger on them because
I've kind of from that the death of my
father developed a process that kind of
says I think that he gave me everything
that he was supposed to give me I had
him for 15 years it was that that's
better than 14.
um so I had him for the time I had him
and everything that he needed to dump
into me he did and I have given that off
to my children and the people around me
that I love and care about
um so I believe that life unfolds in a
way that it should and I trust that each
moment even the negative moments are
what we're supposed to endure it's what
we're supposed to have them it's
adversity we're supposed to learn from
them Nelson Mandela said quote I use all
the time in life we never lose we either
win or we learn right so that the loss
of my dad I learned after a long stretch
of time I looked back saying man my dad
in here I wonder why they took him away
he was a good dude and then I ended up
doing great work with kids that were 14
15 16 years old who looked like me that
didn't have a dad in their home so I
could relate to them that was became
parts of Cornerstone of my life's work
so the the information the process I
went through of losing my dad and
growing up without him at 15 helped me
be a better version of support for those
young men that didn't have their dads in
their home so when I started working
with them all all of a sudden I said man
now I understand that even that negative
moment helped me be better for young men
that I support
um so just learning from it I think it
was I think I'm an optimist by Nature I
don't know if my wife would agree with
that or not but hell I'm gonna sell it
is that I think I'm an optimist I see
the world I see the world is positive
and I see the world as beneficial so if
if we choose that that's what will come
to us I believe that right the vibration
you put out the energy you put out
people will tune into it you'll either
say hey the energy the doc is giving out
I like I like that dude or I don't
really like him if they ask me to talk
to him another time I would say no
because I didn't like his energy right
that's that's kind of how it works I
hope to be good enough in terms of the
energy that people will vibe with me
um and it'll be positive that's my hope
so my version of that is my one of my
mantras that I'm trying to work through
is great things happen to me it's like a
daily reminder great things happen to me
great things happen great things happen
to me great so this morning I was
actually tested because we woke up we
wake up my wife's going to the bank
account to our business bank accounts
and see zero dollars in both accounts
uh that's a big problem you know like
there should be there should be money
there because I got payroll I got 42
people on the team like we gotta there
should be money there uh it's like okay
you know what great things happen to me
and uh and we whatever we called them we
called the bank or just a glitch and
like on the reporting system and the
money's there it's like but like Evan
from 10 years ago would have had like a
full-on panic attack like oh my God
what's going on this is crazy so uh I
mean it seems to be working at least for
me in the growth how can we get there
faster like how do you get people to
adopt that mindset whether it's great
things happen to me or
um for you it's like learning the trust
is gonna unfold as it needs to how do
how do we start to get there because I
think I don't think most people live
there so I would say
I'm not in the business of getting there
faster
I'm in the business of getting there
when I'm supposed to and when and when
we're supposed to get Evan you weren't
supposed to get that you were supposed
to be who you were 10 years ago
so now the contrast in that right the
contrasting growth allows you to better
understand how important it is who you
are today because you can contrast it to
the evidence 10 years ago so get we get
there when we choose to get there when
the moment occurs for us is what I
believe so I don't think it's a race I
really don't I think that where I'm at
today is exactly where I'm supposed to
be and if I if I seek to move or change
the things in me that that means it
starts when I begin that change process
I love that this great things are gonna
happen to me Mantra it's one thing I do
in my work in the NBA with players I'm I
tell them create mantras multiple
mantras when you're going to the free
throw line you should have a mantra that
settles and sues you something that you
say to yourself over and over as you
walk to the free throw line right or
when moments are negative in the game
you should have another Mantra that you
repeat to yourself I love this great
things happen to me that's a that's
calling in positivity right I'm gonna
steal that um you can use it yeah
yes I'm using that but but another thing
though I heard you say this word and I
think this is a word that we should
delete from the Lexicon and the word and
the word is and the word is try
okay we don't try anything either we do
or we don't
either we get things done or we do not
there is no I don't believe that there's
any trap I'm gonna try to call you at
two o'clock Evan no either I'm gonna
call you at two I'm not gonna call you
and I know when I tell you that I'm
gonna try at two I know if I'm gonna
call you or not now probably not when I
say I'm a try I know right so engaging
in with the language that we use I think
matters it moves Us in certain ways the
positivity negativity that we have I
think it moves Us in certain ways and we
gotta we have to tune into that you're
you're a modern day Yoda
do or do not there is no try don't try
that's it I love it I love it
um you talk about the free throw line
and one of my favorite stories uh was
when you started working with NBA
athletes you asked them hey what happens
between the time somebody follows you
and you step up to the free-fold line
you got 20 seconds like what's going on
in your minds like I don't know I'm just
waiting for the ball and like Okay so
let's use that I love how you you can
find in micro moments to inject
intentionality into somebody's routine
so in the case of uh maybe that example
what do you what should an NBA player do
in that 20 seconds before they get to
the free throw line so what so one thing
I talked to them about is slowing things
down I think we can hear that in life
than the normal person that's moving
around the world doing the day-to-day
job that they do is find moments that we
can slow things down
um I think that we were in such a hustle
of bustle all day every day and
sometimes it's good but sometimes it's
not we need moments of Stillness
um to settle ourselves because as an NBA
athlete when you go to the free throw
line did a little research if you can
bring that heart rate down from 140 to
128 the chances of your free throws
going in increase it may only be a four
to seven four to five percent increase
but I'll take that I would always think
four to five percent increase he's in
business and free throws and anything so
if we can find those micro moments to
manage in such a way that we gain
benefit we should be doing that right
it's small but and incremental but
important so if we turn it to the
entrepreneurial world or use me as an
example uh before I get on stage I'm
usually super nervous before I do an
interview like this I'm like okay we got
to get ready when our question is going
to ask you and research you know my
heart's probably not slowing down uh
what should my process be you know I'm
about to go on an airplane and talk to
my my neighbor now because Dr Yeager
told me to and I'm panicking
what what uh what should my ritual be as
I'm stepping onto the airplane you know
so my Palms aren't sweaty I think
there's a quick and dirty thing that you
can do that could be helpful is to focus
on your breathing I don't people say
that all the time but if we focus on our
breathing in in the moment it brings you
into the current moment it does not
allow you to focus on the past it does
not allow you to be pondering what's
going to happen in the future when you
get on that plane but it brings you into
the current moment and let's be clear
about this then the only thing we truly
have in this whole world is this moment
that we're in so in true thing
everything else is made up in the mind
everything else is made up in the mind
that what happened is you're drawing
from memories that are made up in the
mind
and what's gonna happen is made up I
think this is going to happen to that
that's all made up the only thing you
have is this moment remind yourself
bring yourself to this moment focus on
your breathing breathe deep bring
yourself back in there as you are
getting on the plane as you're going on
stage bring yourself in the moment today
but my Mantra is that I use all the time
is I'm Built For This
I'm built for this I say it all the time
I'm built for this so whatever comes my
way I'm built for it
um so that moment I'm built for this
moment I don't know about 10 minutes
but I know I'm built for this moment so
stay in that moment that's a little
trick I think that we should use that
that's helpful I love that I'm built I
might steal that one from you there you
go great things happen to me and nothing
for this
I love it man what time can you take us
through like 20 seconds of of breathing
like you would like if if the NBA
All-Star comes up and says hey Dr Yeager
like how do I breathe well like what
would you I would say hey so hold on
we're going to do let's take a second or
two here yeah tune in just stay pay
attention just breathe regular for the
next five seconds just pay attention to
what that feels like how deep that goes
how long that last count that count that
breath as it goes in and count it as it
goes out just your normal breath now you
have a frame of understanding of what
your normal breath feels and how long it
goes so now let's take a deeper breath
how long was that breath that you took
well I was three seconds in so let's go
five seconds in let's get a really deep
deep breath and let's hold that percent
second once we get it and then let's
blow it out for three ah now let's do
that again let's repeat that right that
three that five seconds in holding it
for a second blowing it out see so if
you focus on that F you did you couldn't
if you were really focused on it you
couldn't focus on the past or the future
you had to force yourself in this moment
right I think it's an easy trick
that we should use
I love it you got the voice for it too
man I think I think the uh the doctor
Jaeger uh meditation apps are coming out
soon deep breathe with me I I think you
got it I I think that's a big hit that's
a hit
[Laughter]
in looking backwards he kind of
mentioned but living in the past
um you use a great example of hey even
oppression athletes will go to the
locker room when they watch the tape of
of yesterday's game like where they made
mistakes but they don't live there
they're not like the next 12 hours
thinking about that one mistake or the
next you know months like we will like
we made a mistake and we're stuck in the
past how do we learn from our mistakes
and the things that we've done and and
you know we screwed up in the past cool
but not live there and go go to a new
place be the river we have to trust the
fact that there is a lesson in the in
that loss or that negativity or whatever
that is that when we first have to trust
that the lesson is there and then if I
can find that lesson and hold it and and
grab it and and utilize it for now then
I don't have to stay back there I think
we stay back there because we don't
trust the lesson that we're supposed to
get from it so now we keep going back in
that and keep it lingering back and
lingering back as an athlete if you
watch film I don't need to watch that
clip 700 times of someone dunking on me
I need to know that when he comes in the
lane I need to move my feet because if
not he'll dunk on my ass so I can learn
from that moment I don't have to live in
that moment so I think this is the
reason that we don't we get stuck in
those negative moments because we don't
learn so we can apply that info and
learn we can move on and leave that
there leave it behind but we must gain
the learning this is great do you have a
YouTube channel
now I have an old man and I am old all I
have is a book
yeah this is what I got that's what I
got here I got a book we need to delete
the word old from the Lexicon
[Laughter]
perfect I love it yeah honestly because
I think you've got and listen for
everybody YouTube we'll link that up uh
the book is so how am I doing Dr Corey
go go check it out somebody the first
part in the description
um
but yeah man like you've got such a
great message and some of the best
content now is just is this this is like
coaching where somebody comes on and
says hey I'm sure Dr Yeager I'm
struggling with blank and then you just
help them yeah and that's a great video
that like a lot of people can it doesn't
just help you sell books and speaking
gigs everything else but like it's a
great service to people that others who
are struggling with the same thing they
can learn anyway I'll plan for a little
bit I'll help you I'll help you maybe
we'll we'll talk afterwards I'll plant
in a seed we we need to see Dr Yeager on
YouTube I think it's great I know that's
my dog that's my new dog right there
we're visualizing the success of the
YouTube channel already and changing the
world let's go make it happen Captain
yeah Oprah had her her Oprah Winfrey
Show and now Dr Yeager is going on to
YouTube he's gonna dominate that let's
go there baby put it out there let's go
I love it uh one one last thing that I
want your your opinion on uh I've got a
bag of Doritos behind me and this is
this is like a big bag of Doritos this
is like if I hold it up it's like it's
like it's like the half human size yeah
yeah now people always ask me like hey
is Doritos sponsoring your videos that's
so unhealthy like you shouldn't do that
here's why I have it and I love this I'd
love to take see or take whether whether
you think I'm just a masochist or uh or
it's a good strategy when when people
are on a diet the common advice is get
all the junk food out of your house
which I normally do what I was doing
before but then I realized in my own
head that's a decision that's making me
feel weaker feel weaker because I'm
telling myself at least for me that I
can't be in a room with the junk food
and I don't like that feeling okay so
then I decided no I'm gonna have I love
Doritos that's like my favorite that's
my go-to if I needed something so I want
to be in front of it all day long just
as a reminder of who I want to be I love
that you like that I think that's smart
as hell okay yeah but but that means you
got it but you move through the world
with the sharpness I can already tell
you guys are sharpness I read a little
bit about you ended up figuring out how
to go from poor grades to good grades
and all so you have a sharpness everyone
can't it doesn't have that willpower to
be able to have that bag behind them
because they're going short out because
they're going to get on a call and it
don't go well and then call in and
they're opening that damn back because
I'm struggling but you have something
that says no I have the willpower and
now I don't have the willpower but I'll
leave it right there and remind myself
that I do have the willpower and prove
to myself every day let it sit right
there I'm good
see that so I think some people can do
that e
some people don't they haven't built
that skin that tough skin that edge that
sharpness to be able to do that
um but that's a journey man right that's
part of that Journey wall you gotta walk
that Journey maybe you grow grow into a
space where you can do that but everyone
can I like that though if I was there
I'm opening a bag
I call it I call it damn the Doritos
because like damn the Doritos they're
not stronger than me damn the Doritos
gain the Doritos but listen I see it as
like if you break your leg then then you
need crutches and a cast right like you
broke your leg so cool but but the
ultimate goal is to not be unconscious
for your whole life the ultimate goal is
to walk again and to run again so if in
the short term we need to get the stuff
out of your house because you broke your
cool but the goal becomes like because
then what happens you go on a cruise
ship you go on vacation or whatever
you're just destroying all the food
because you taught yourself that yeah
anyway so cool it's it's Dr Yeager
approved I like it thank you uh the man
is Dr coreyager the book is how am I
doing 40 conversations to have with
yourself we'll link it up there below go
pick up that book go check out his
upcoming YouTube channel
appreciate you man thanks for the time
[Laughter]
much love take care thank you man if you
want to see the one-on-one I recently
did with Les Brown check it out right
there next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there whatever you see yourself doing
now
you're marching toward purpose
meaning and impact